health care we're continuing our
coverage of Donald Trump's bizarre
moments from recent interviews there are
far too many of them to cover in one day
and one of them has everything to do
with the continued attempts to repeal
and replace Obamacare the Affordable
Care Act Donald Trump did an interview
on Face the Nation with John Dickerson
and it became very quickly clear that
Trump has no idea what's in the new
health care bill that he's advocating
for we still don't know whether this
bill has a shot at passing earlier today
it appeared as though maybe Republicans
could get the votes that they need in
the house but it's still not clear and
during the interview at a few different
points Dickerson pointed out major flaws
with the bill like for example older
people and low-income people and people
with pre-existing conditions would
likely all pay significantly higher
premiums and each time that Dickerson
mentioned this during the interview
Trump said oh it's all fixed up don't
worry about it
which of course isn't true which
suggests to me and this might not come
as a surprise to you Pat the Trump has
no idea what's even in this health care
bill and when Dickerson said to Trump
well can you explain how those things
are fixed Trump had nothing to say take
a look at this so but in the bill if it
was analyzed there were two problems one
and you talked about this with
congressman Robert aderholt who brought
you the example of the 64 year old who
under Obamacare the premiums would bring
us that was a lifetime ago Jim we have
it I won't totally sense how it's all
fixed wait how do you want me to explain
how that's a different story John but
it's all fixed dickerson later in the
interview also had to inform Trump about
whether or not the current iteration of
the bill allows the purchasing of
insurance across state lines or Trump
likes to call them borders we call them
state lines here's a piece of that we
have now pre-existing conditions in the
bill we have we've set up a pool for the
pre-existing condition so that the
premiums can be allowed to fall we're
taking across all of the borders or the
line so that insurance companies can
compete but the nation in the borders
questions end up in the third bill right
because it's in the second say Trump has
no clue what's going on it's in the
second phase of the second bill versus
the
first phase of the third bill and by the
way John it's all fixed I'm sure you're
not going to be surprised by this but
I'm legitimately confused because I
thought the first bill allowed the
pre-existing condition provision to stay
and that they would get rid of it in
this new unofficial plan and that also
they wouldn't be even allowed to pass
the new state line provision because
that would be subject to a filibuster by
the Democrats not only that I actually
thought that a lot of the provisions
that were not in the first bill that
were put in the second bill are put in
there on paper but you're also adding
that states can request waivers out of
those provisions so it's almost like not
having them at all
what I think we need to wait for is the
third iteration of phase two of bill
number four that's when I think we're
really going to get down to the
nitty-gritty and of course Donald Trump
knows all of this because he's a very
detailed or yeah as we heard about
yesterday Trump's all about the details
later in the interview Trump went on to
talk about just how to tremendously
great the bill is for people with
pre-existing conditions even though
again most of the prevention the
provisions to protect people with
pre-existing conditions have been
removed and Trump went as far as to say
that people with pre-existing conditions
are going to be covered quote
beautifully which really raises my
suspicions about whether Trump has any
idea what's in this bill and B Slavit
the Medicare and Medicaid administrator
during the last part of the Obama
administration he went on Twitter and
said quote would the White House staff
please mind showing him the actual
American healthcare act plan it raises
premiums deductibles and removes
pre-existing conditions protections Jake
Sherman from Politico went on Twitter
and he tweeted striking in Dickerson's
Trump interview the president really
cannot describe the difference between
the versions of the health care bill
there's two reasons why Trump is having
so much trouble explaining what's in
this bill the first one is obvious that
he's clueless and he doesn't really know
what's in the bill as a general matter
but number two this is yet again another
one of these haphazardly thrown together
bills after the first as I drop my
sharpie
after the first healthcare bill failed
Trump has barely had any time to
familiarize himself with it he's barely
familiar with any of the stuff that he's
signing or supporting but there's a
number of factors here
I remember when Nancy Pelosi got a lot a
lot of flack for saying that we have to
pass the Affordable Care Act so we can
find out what's in it for us there was
certainly a gap and you know not the
best use of words there but at least the
Affordable Care Act Obamacare was about
2,000 pages long and he wasn't going to
sit down read the entire thing the
American Health Care Act
Trump's bill is only 66 pages you can do
that in an afternoon
yeah but Trump doesn't read 66 pages
remember that I'm sure that the 66 pages
were condensed into a single picture I'm
sorry a single page half of which was a
picture and then three bullet points
because that's how Trump likes to get
his information and as with everything
else
haphazard no one knows what's going on
and it's unclear whether this has the
the votes to pass and I think shouldn't
we know in the next 24 to 48 hours if
the house will have the votes to pass
this thing that's what I'm hearing if
only we had a third person here because
I do not know yeah or if only we had
some device where we could look that up
that would be really really useful know
that basically the Republicans in the
house are within a few votes one way or
the other of being able to pass this
thing and of course then we'd have to
see what happens in the Senate but we'll
be following it it's clear Trump won't
have any idea what's in this thing many
many discussions about this at david
pakman.com slash read it today's program
is made possible in part by Gamefly
which is sort of like netflix for video
games they've got over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can also stream games you don't
even need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial
and Gamefly offer.com /t DPS the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30-day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com /t DPS